[Musik]
vier wochen sind wir unterwegs an der
süd von in der ukraine in der roten zone
in einer welt in der schönheit hoffnung
angst und zerstörung so nah beieinander
lägen
wir treffen menschen die lässig und
mondän dem russischen rakete nagel
trotzen und die auch mitten im krieg
immer nur nach vorne schauen und
doch damit rechnen müssen in jeder
sekunde aus dem leben gerissen zu werden
[Musik]
es ist eine welt voller widersprüche in
der wir immer auf alles vorbereitet sein
müssen in einem krieg der droht die welt
mit sich zu reißen und in dem auch der
hunger zur waffe wird
von faschisten und kommunisten wurde
dieses land im letzten jahrhundert
geplündert und zerstört und wir spüren
dass für die menschen hier eine
niederlage nicht infrage kommt denn für
sie geht es um alles um ihr überleben
als nation
[Musik]
wir sind in der weltberühmten oper von
odessa einem der schönsten theater und
opernhäusern der welt ein ort des
friedens und der erbauung ein ort der
schönen künste
die oper ist das wahrzeichen der stadt
und nationales symbol ukrainischer
kultur jetzt aber mitten im krieg mit
russland bereitet man sich darauf vor
dass dieses symbol ukrainischer
identität durch russische raketen
ausgelöscht wird denn russland verfolge
mit seinem krieg einen plan erzählt uns
der ukrainischen kulturminister
[Musik]
es kämpft gegen unsere identität
denn was steht für identität kultur
geschichte sprach
in dem moment in dem putin der ukraine
das recht abgesprochen hat unabhängig zu
sein das land demokratisch zu regieren
in dem moment wurde natürlich unsere
kultur und geschichte zum angriff
mehr als 370 kultureinrichtungen wurden
bislang von russischen raketen zerstört
so dass ukrainische
kulturministerium
projekten tänzer musiker sie alle werden
zu feinden in einem krieg und dem
russland sie vernichten und als nation
zerstören will so sehen sie das hier und
so werden auch tänzerinnen und tänzer zu
kriegern im kampf ums überleben
[Musik]
wir haben kollegen die im kampf sind an
der front die richtig kämpfen der armee
und der territorialverteidigung
[Musik]
viele helfen als freiwillig selbst
helfer als freiwilliger jeden tag
andere helfen bei der logistik
jeder hilft tut was er kann
und wir helfen unserem land mit unserer
arbeit auch an dieser zweiten front
an diesem wochenende wie die oper wieder
eröffnen will sie der welt zeigen und
sich die ukraine den russischen plänen
nicht beugen wird und doch kann im
nächsten moment alles schon vorbei sein
erklärt uns der sprecher des gouverneurs
es ist gefährlich in der stadt die
raketen können jederzeit einschlagen
auch hier wo wir jetzt stehen aber eines
ist auch ganz klar wir werden nicht
aufgeben wir werden gewinnen
[Musik]
lässig entspannt monday
morbider charme des zaren und des
sowjetreiches
und deshalb die perle am schwarzen meer
mitten im krieg von dem sie sich nicht
aus der ruhe bringen lassen um der doch
allgegenwärtig ist
[Musik]
immer wieder schlagen russische raketen
im stadtgebiet ein zerstören kritische
infrastruktur reißen ohne vorwarnung
dazu familien aus dem leben am
hellichten tag wie hier beim mittagessen
immer wieder luftalarm immer wieder
russische cruise missile im anflug auf
das stadtgebiet sie haben sich daran
gewöhnt das leben muss weitergehen und
doch bereiten sie sich darauf vor dass
russische truppen vielleicht doch einmal
durch ihre straßen marodieren
jeder auf seine weise
das ist ein molotow-cocktail sollte denn
sein bier und weinflaschen eignen sich
dafür ganz gut
wenn sie kommen dann schmeißen wir sie
aus den fenstern und von den dächern das
funktioniert recht gut
alexander hat sich kurz vor dem krieg
eine edle weinbar aufgebaut und er
handelt mit ukrainischen weinen die er
für völlig unterschätzt hätten das
geschäft sei seit beginn des krieges
dramatisch eingebrochen viele seiner
kunden die eher zu den wohlhabenden
gehören hätten die stadt wegen der
ständigen luftangriffe
stiege verlassen er selbst hat seine
frau und tochter nach bulgarien
geschickt er aber werde bis zum ende
bleiben für sein geschäft und seine
zukunft kämpfen die ihr in europa sieht
wo er bereit sei für einen frieden mit
russland fragen wir ihn
die sache ist doch ganz einfach nach
diesen gräueltaten in mario pohl
bouchareb ihn gibt es nur eine
schlussfolgerung
wir sind nicht durch all das gegangen um
irgendwelche konzessionen oder
kompromisse zu machen was unser
staatsgebiet unter unsere lebensweise
eine niederlage gegen russland das seine
zukunft zerstören wolle sie den ex under
noch nicht einmal in betracht
an der küste vor der suche ukrainische
truppen den horizont ab bei gutem wetter
könne man sie sehen die russischen
kriegsschiffe die weit draußen vor
odessa kreuzen wir sind in einer der
unzähligen befestigungsanlagen der stadt
hier bereiten sie sich auf eine
russische landungsoperation vor
wir haben seit beginn des krieges damit
gerechnet dass ihr kommen wir verstärken
und befestigen unsere anlagen jeden tag
auch wenn es derzeit ruhig sei nur
deshalb die ruhe sei trügerisch meinen
die soldaten die russischen truppen
hätten und besser als ziel nicht
aufgegeben
an manchen tagen schicken sie 20 bis 30
drohnen über unsere stellungen
ein paar hätten sie hier schon vom
himmel geschossen immer wieder stehen
drohen ukrainische verteidigungsanlagen
haus der ukrainische geheimdienst warnt
die bevölkerung die kriegsschiffe und u
boote vor der küste hätten neue raketen
geladen und deshalb ist für den krieg
seien im kreml ein strategisch wichtiges
ziel doch allein von see her ist die
stadt nicht einzunehmen
währenddessen ihren strategisch
wichtigen hafen erobern will muss auch
vom land her angreifen dafür aber müssen
die russischen truppen erster mahlow des
nachbarstadt niculae von ihre
umliegenden dörfer einnehmen seit beginn
des krieges wird hier gekämpft
letzte vorbereitungen für uns geht es in
die rote zone ein kampfgebiet hinter der
vordersten front unserer
rettungssanitäter und ex-soldat jarrett
erklärt uns noch einmal das tor nickel
mit dem mann eine schwere blutung
verbindet
sie ist schnell und fest an nur die
blutung nicht auf andere weise stoppen
kannst
es sei das wichtigste medizinische
hilfsmittel in einem kriegsgebiet
die sogenannte rote zone um nikolai
wurde zwar von ukrainischen truppen
zurückerobert doch immer wieder gibt es
angriffe und vorstoß der russen wir
müssen auf alles vorbereitet sein meinte
witt immer mit dabei der erste hilfe
rucksack
zwei stunden fahrt liegen vor uns immer
wieder checkpoints des militärs und der
polizei die wir aus sicherheitsgründen
nicht drehen dürfen
anders als er nur besser ist die
stimmung in mikulov angespannt spürt man
den krieg an jeder ecke stehen menschen
an tanklastern an die sie mit
trinkwasser versorgen seit monaten
greift das russische militär auch die
zivile infrastruktur an
wir beten zu gott dass alles gute
bitte erzählt allen dass wir alles
ertragen
wir müssen wieder stimme
damit unser leben so wie es war zurück
praktisch jeden tag wird nikolai von der
schweren beschuss gelegt auch als wir
ankommen halt immer wieder kanonendonner
durch die stadt einen monat nach
kriegsbeginn zerstört ein russischer
marschflugkörper den verwaltungs- und
amtssitz des gouverneurs
36 menschen sterben an einem
frühlingsmorgen um 80 47 alles sie will
ist
die metro platten schock vom militär
bezirk mikula führt uns durch das
gebäude und für ihn ist klar wem der
angriff galt
christmas so dass im park vom front doch
die rakete kam von da drüben und ging
direkt in das büro von gouverneur king
da oben im
worst case office den gouverneur war
hätten sie nicht getroffen die russen
seien zu blöd gewesen erzählt uns die
metro sie hätten nicht gedacht dass die
ukraine auf sommerzeit umgestellt hatte
und so sei die rakete eine stunde zu
früh eingeschlagen gouverneur sei noch
nicht im büro gewesen ob das stimmt
lässt sich natürlich nicht überprüfen
aber es zeigt dass man keine hohe
meinung von seinem feind hat und aus
jedem wort wird klar wie simon russland
verachtet und misstraut
an diesem tag am 29 märz hatten wir mit
russland verhandelt und immer wenn
russland von frieden spricht dann machen
sie so
ein angriff an der front oder auf die
zivile infrastruktur
das ist die fratze von putins welt das
ist staatsterrorismus
der amtssitz des gouverneurs in schutt
und asche gelegt das gebäude kann nur
noch abgerissen werden warum
ausgerechnet nikolajew seine zivile und
wirtschaftliche infrastruktur seit
monaten so massiv unter feuer gelegt
wird wollen wir noch von ihm wissen
nikolov ist ein strategisch wichtiger
punkt bisher haben es die russen nicht
geschafft in unsere richtung vorzustoßen
und dann auf besser zu marschieren und
weil sie das nicht geschafft haben haben
sie ihre strategie geändert und die
stadt unter permanentes bombardement
gelegt sie beschießen uns mit artillerie
von flugzeugen und von schiffen
was der dauerbeschuss mit den menschen
macht können wir nur erahnen als wir die
stadt verlassen
für uns geht es weiter zu den front
dörfern in der umkämpften roten zone es
ist eines der wichtigsten
landwirtschaftlichen anbau gebiete der
ukraine vor allem weizen
sonnenblumenkerne und raps werden hier
für den weltmarkt produziert
bis vor kurzem wurde hier noch gekämpft
die russischen bodentruppen konnten
zurückgedrängt werden immer wieder aber
versuchen sie durch zu brechen
regelmäßig wird auch diese ländliche
region mit artillerie und raketen
beschossen wir werden jetzt begleitet
von oberleutnant oder zielinski von der
63 brigade zu unserer sicherheit
an einer behelfsbrücke machen wir halt
der oberleutnant wird uns etwas zeigen
dass hier im fluss sind russische grad
überall dem wasser sind überall
die eigentliche geschichte aber sei wie
diese raketen in den fluss gekommen sein
sie sage viel aus darüber wie intensiv
die kämpfe nach wie vor auch an der
südfront sind die bauern hier hätten auf
ihre weise zwei russische
munitionstransporter zerstört die defekt
zurückgelassen wurden
sie haben erst mit messern die reifen
zerstochen und dann die batterien
ausgebaut
was genau passiert ist werden wir später
erfahren
in einem kleinen dorf hinter der brücke
beginnen wir zu verstehen dass es bei
diesem krieg um sehr viel mehr geht als
um kämpfe zwischen soldaten dass dieser
krieg in der ukraine an mehreren fronten
gekämpft wird auch in der landwirtschaft
auf einem feldweg vor uns ein total
zerstört der traktor wir halten an all
unser begleiter von der ukrainischen
armee sagt wir sollten ein bisschen
vorsichtig sein und aufpassen wo wir hin
treten der trecker sei auf eine mine
gefahren
die straße ist jetzt sicher da geht auf
keinen fall neben die straße oder auf
die felder da konnten wir noch nicht
räumen
wir haben zu wenig
wir sind gerade alle vorne an der front
der treckerfahrer ist umgekommen als er
gleich nachdem die russischen truppen
zurückgedrängt wurden seine felder
bestellen wollte der soldat bewundert
den mut der bau ich kann nur sagen er
war ein held ich bin soldat des
ukrainischen militärs die bauern kämpfen
an der zweiten folge der wirtschaftlich
damit die welt nicht hungern
ein paar kilometer weiter treffen wir
den bauern mehr ohne job
er zeigt uns womit sie hier auf den
feldern jeden tag zu kämpfen haben
mitten im rapsfeldern bombenkrater ein
russisches kampfflugzeuge seine felder
bombardiert
sie bombardieren unsere dörfer und
felder wir finden ihre bomben an orten
an denen es überhaupt kein militär
look zeigt uns ein getreidelager er habe
glück gehabt dass er seine ernte
rechtzeitig in den hafen bringen konnte
bevor die russischen truppen gekommen
sein wieder andere bauen die noch unter
russischer besatzung lägen hätten alles
verloren
sie stehlen die mähdrescher und
landmaschinen sie stehen getreide und
saatgut und bringen alles nach russland
und auf die grenzen
wir sind jetzt nicht mehr weit von der
front entfernt 15 20 kilometer im
hintergrund immer wieder kanonendonner
die bauern hier aber lassen sich nicht
verschrecken sie sind artillerie und
raketen angriffe seit beginn des krieges
gewohnt
nadia ivanova managern die große farmen
frontgebiet sie produzieren hier
normalerweise 10.000 tonnen
sonnenblumenkernen für die ölproduktion
und ein paar tausend tonnen getreide
oder sieht ganz danach aus als hätten
ist die russischen truppen gezielt auf
ihre farm abgesehen auf dem boden in der
maschinenhalle überall helle weiße
punkte licht das durch die vielen löcher
im dach fällt war das streumunition
viele geschossen ist
mehrfach wird der große hof getroffen
mähdrescher traktoren sprüh fahrzeuge
vieles sei zerstört und könne derzeit
nicht repariert werden weil sich die
mechaniker der firma aus kiew wegen des
permanenten beschuss nicht hierher
trauen würden
wenn sie hören dass wir aus nikolajew
sind dann wollen sie nicht kommen
in der halle beim altmetall die reste
einer rakete die auf den hof abgefeuert
wurde nadja verfällt in galgenhumor
das ist unsere ernte raketen granaten
geschosse drohnen viel davon einfach
alles
große teile der farm sind zerstört nach
die als landarbeiter zeigen uns was sie
jeden tag so finden wir
fragen nach dem was sie denn glaubt
warum die russen farmen wie ihre
angreifen würden
als unser gouverneur nach den ersten
angriffen gesagt hat die leute sollten
sich keine sorgen machen die versorgung
sei gesichert wir hätten genügend
getreide in den lagern und bei den
bauern haben wir festgestellt dass sie
die angriffe auf unsere fahnen und lager
verstärkt haben sie haben gezielt auf
die silos geschossen in denen das meiste
getreide gelagert war
gezielte angriffe auf bauern- und farmen
das werden kriegsverbrechen und dann ist
da noch ein anderes problem ein teil der
ernte aus dem vergangenen jahr konnten
sie zwar retten aber jetzt bekämen sie
die ernte nicht los wir haben viele
probleme das größte ist dass die häfen
durch die russen blockiert sind kein
schiff kann die helfen und die
ukrainischen gewässer verlassen die
lager nehmen kein getreide mehr an sind
voll wir können nicht exportieren unsere
produkte auf dem weltmarkt verkaufen
mehr als 25 millionen tonnen getreide
und andere agrarprodukte können nicht
ausgeführt werden weil dir helfen wir
nun besser und nikolov durch die
russische marine blockiert werden
mindestens 50 millionen tonnen kommen in
diesen wochen durch die neue ernte noch
hinzu
auf unserem weg durch die rote zone
kleine bauern siedlungen viele haben
noch nicht mal einen offiziellen
[Musik]
es ist ein armes einfaches ein hartes
leben sie leben von dem was ihnen das
land gibt es ist alles was sie haben
als die russischen truppen zu beginn des
krieges einmarschieren und ihre existenz
bedrohen wehrt sich jeder zu gute kam
da drüben stand einer ihrer lkw
ich habe meinen traktor genommen und den
lkw zu unseren soldaten gebracht damit
sie ihn für ersatzteile ausschlachten
können
wir haben uns mit svetlana wand so lapp
redet sie ist bäuerin eine art gemeinde
vorsteherin sieben bauern siedlungen
liegen in ihrem zuständigkeitsbereich
gleich bei unserer ankunft dumpf
artillerie donner in der ferne
was genau ist es
das kann kann den russen die schießen in
unsere richtung sie zielen auf unsere
dörfer und städte sie wollen unsere
verteidigungslinien durchbrechen um
wieder zurückzukommen aber unsere
soldaten halten die stimmen
schon einmal waren die russen hier und
ihr ruf eilte ihm voraus
entführung vergewaltigung raub und mord
in den nachbardörfern alle hier wussten
was ihnen blüht wenn die russischen
truppen ihre gemeinde besetzt
svitlana rennt auf die straße als die
russen kommen dokumentiert den einmarsch
mit einem handyvideo da sie sofort zur
warnung an alle über die sozialen medien
verbreitet bei not afraid ob sie keine
angst gehabt hätte fragen wir sind
die russen geschrieben haben ich soll
reingehen und mit dem gewehr auf mich
gezielt habe aber ich zurückgeschrieben
das ist meine heimat mein haus und wo
erzählst mir nicht was ich in meiner
heimat zu tun habe ich bin ukrainerin
ich fürchte mich nicht was ist meine
mit einer siedlung konnten die
russischen invasoren schnell vertrieben
werden und svetlana hatte daran ihren
anteil wie wir später noch erfahren
werden viele nachbardörfer aber sind
besetzt svitlana seine lebensmittelhilfe
organisiert für die die fliehen konnten
ihr ganzes leben sei ihnen genommen
worden sagen sie uns über das was ihnen
und ihren familien angetan wurde wollen
sie nicht sprechen
ich schaue nach vorne auch wenn man
ihnen an merkt was sie durchgemacht
haben müssen
egal wie schwer es wird um wir werden
alles wieder aufbauen wenn wir wieder
zurückkommen wir werden auf jeden fall
wieder zurückkommen
[Musik]
da
wir übernachten im kindergarten der
gemeinde
beim abendessen warten svetlana dass wir
bei anbruch der dunkelheit kein licht
machen dürften damit das dorf nicht so
zielscheibe das
die ganze nacht kreisen drohnen über uns
[Musik]
der nächste morgen ein friedlich
ländliches idyll weit ab so wird es von
den großen verwerfungen des
weltgeschehens doch viel haben sie hier
schon erlebt maria wurde in einem
arbeitslager in graz geboren ihre eltern
von den nazis verschleppt
ich bin durch das alles schon mal
gegangen als ich klein war ich hätte
niemals geglaubt dass ich am ende meines
lebens wieder einen solchen krieg
jahrhunderte wurde die menschen hier von
fremden mächten überfallen ausgeraubt
bestohlen mindestens vier millionen
bauern des staates an der ukraine
verhungern sie wurden immer als menschen
zweiter klasse behandelt auch und
besonders der sowjetunion
unser leben war gerade dabei immer
besser zu werden und dann kam dieser
krieg
ist sehr unheimlich alles die russen
waren hier wir waren direkt an der front
von hier haben wir sie zurückgeschlagen
niemals würden sie sich den russen
ergeben das steht für die menschen hier
fast aber auch wenn sie die russischen
truppen aus dem dorf vertrieben hätten
ihre hinterlassenschaften könnten für
sie alles verändert
bevor wir unsere kühe wieder auf die
weide bringen konnten mussten die
minenräumer kommen ich habe heute wieder
welche gesehen sie müssen wieder
irgendetwas gefunden habe
[Musik]
svitlana die gemeinde vorsteherin hat
einen kleinen minensuchtrupp angefordert
in den vergangenen tagen seien immer
wieder kühe auf mein getreten und
explodiert
sie nimmt uns mit auf der weide ein
kleiner trupp zwei man alles sieht recht
hemdsärmlig aus dem kofferraum eine
russische panzermine die würde man nicht
sprengen die seien noch gut die könne
man wieder einsetzen
wir haben da die rakete von einem
raketenwerfer gefunden bislang nur eine
wir könnten ihnen folgen sollten aber
wenn möglich durchs hohe gras ihren
fußstapfen folgen und ein bisschen
abstand halten falls sie doch etwas
übersehen
an dem kleinen minensuchtrupp hängt die
zukunft der gemeinde denn die felder und
wiesen sind übersät mit granaten panzern
das ist eine grad-rakete weg hier geht
das auto
sprengstoff und zünder sind an der
rakete angebracht sergej zieht das kabel
und geht mit uns hinter dem auto
entdeckung
nur wo geräumt sein könnten die bauern
arbeiten mindestens fünf jahre würde es
dauern bis alle felder und wiesen
geräumt sein und das nur wenn die russen
nicht wiedererkennen eine katastrophe
sei das für die dörfer hier an der front
sagt und svetlana wand wir können auf
vielen beiden kein heu machen unsere
kühe werden hungern wir werden sie im
winter nicht füttern können
in diesem krieg geht es für die menschen
hier ums nackte überleben alles steht
für sie auf dem spiel und deswegen haben
sie auch alle gegen die russischen
truppen gekämpft auch die bäuerin und
gemeindevorsteher ins mit langer mantel
aber mit dabei ganz vorne an der front
wir haben ihnen die reifen
aufgeschnitten und die batterien
geklappt bei den raketen haben wir die
zünder aus geschraubt und sie unseren
soldaten gegeben wir sind partisan
als die russen verstehen dass sie ihre
raketen transporter verloren haben jagen
sie die lkw mit panzergranaten in die
luft damit sie nicht in ukrainische
hände fallen sie sind stolz auf das was
sie hier getan haben aber wie groß angst
und verzweiflung sein müssen wenn eine
bäuerin und gemeinde vorsteherin zu
partisanen wird wenn du uns erst klar
als wir sie fragen welche hilfe sie sich
hier erhoffen
ich wünschte ihr hättet gesehen wie
viele kinder von diesem westen ihr
vergewaltigt wurden sie haben zwei
monate alte babys getötet wie kann da
jemand wechseln oder kanzler soll sich
mal vorstellen dass es seine tochter und
seine kinder sind die vergewaltigt
werden er würde sofort am nächsten tag
den krieg erklären unsere kinder werden
getötet als die russen kamen haben wir
als erstes unsere kinder evakuiert doch
war so leer ohne die kinder und ihr gebt
uns keine waffen
immer wieder hören wir von solchen
verbrechen
auch wenn sie hier viel mitgemacht haben
und dem bösen die augen gesehen haben
die hoffnung auf ein neues ein besseres
leben geben sie nicht auf auch nicht
mitten im krieg auf dem marktplatz der
kleinen kreis statt was stanka treffen
wir olga und mikado mikado war ein hoch
dekorierter pensionierter veteran als er
sich zu beginn des krieges freiwillig
zurück an die front gemeldet hat voller
stolz zeigt er und seine orden
freiheit und er dienst am vaterland
verdienstorden für teilnahme in der
schlacht und so geht es weiter und
weiter auch der tapferkeitsorden ist
dabei und die medaille des präsidenten
für anti terror kampf aber das ist heute
alles nebensache denn für mich keine und
olga ist es ein ganz besonderer tag
micro hat sich extra freigenommen von
der front und auch sein sohn andré ist
mit ein paar kameraden gekommen direkt
aus dem gefecht um den vater zu
gratulieren vater und sohn kämpfen in
der gleichen privat
diesen harten zeiten für die ukraine
muss jeder tun was er kann und das ist
völlig okay wenn väter und söhne brüder
gemeinsam an der front kämpfen das zeigt
unsere einheit und unsere stärke
zur eigentlichen feier aber können
andere und seine kameraden nicht bleiben
sie werden an der front gebracht
[Musik]
für olga und mika es ist die zweite ehe
sie sei so froh dass sie wieder jemanden
habe der in ihrer seite stehe sagt uns
olga und das obwohl auch er gleich
zurück
wir sind eine freundlich und starke
nation es gibt für uns keinen anderen
weg wir werden ein schönes und mächtiges
land werden
drei tage später zerstören russische
raketen die verwaltungsbehörde gleich
neben dem standesamt in dem olga und
mikado geheiratet haben und
uns wird klar wie nahe die menschen hier
in jeder sekunde ihres lebens dem tod
sind
oberleutnant rolex alinghi kann seine
wut kaum verbergen die soldaten würden
sicherer leben als die zivilisten hier
der scheißkerl putin würde die menschen
tyrannisieren und dann fragt er unserem
bundeskanzler noch etwas sagt
olaf gib uns waffen wir brauchen die
waffen dringend um die russen aus
unserem land zu werfen und sie unsere
zivilisten nicht mehr töten und ihre
gebäude zerstören
zurück in odessa in der oper wie für
alle die wir getroffen haben gibt es
auch für die tänzerinnen und tänzer nur
ein akzeptables ende dieses krieges
die einzige hoffnung die ich habe ist
dass wir siegen werden wir gewinnen dann
wird sich unser theater unsere kultur
auch weiterentwickeln können und darum
kommt für mich nur ein sieg
nach vier wochen entlang der südfront
dämmerte sohns
wer glaubt dass die menschen hier jemals
aufgeben und sich geschlagen geben
werden der hat die ukraine nicht
verstanden
[Musik]